Brian Shepard previously the front end
and edge site reliability engineer at
uber had this to say about stack driver
stack driver is a quick and easy utility
to monitor your apps performance within
minutes we had dashboards for compute
instances and VPN statistics an
easy-to-use policy based alert
management system helps us notify
on-call engineers of issues quickly
we're happy you like it Ryan
so do we Google stack driver provides
powerful monitoring logging and
diagnostics it equips you with insight
into the health performance and
availability of plow power and
applications enabling you to find and
fix issues faster it is natively
integrated with Google cloud platform
Amazon Web Services and popular open
source packages stack driver provides a
wide variety of metrics dashboards
alerting log management reporting and
tracing capabilities this hands-on quick
lab will lead you through creating a VM
installing Apache 2 on it and it will
show you how to create an uptime check
on staff driver create an alerting
policy for your uptime check create a
dashboard and chart for CPU load stop
your VM and view to incident notice in
stock driver and view the logs for your
VM with stack driver logging as with all
our lives you do not need a Google cloud
platform account or project an account
project and associated resources are
provided to you as part of this lab if
you already have your own GCP account
don't use it for this lab your one lab
away from completing your quest and
getting your veg in case you haven't
been following our other videos a quest
is a series of related labs that form a
learning path on quick laps completing
this quest earns you this badge to
recognize your achievement next and
final lab on your quest is setting up
network in HTTP load balancers